i know dyson offers says the say at leon
st is more stylish than vw's golf
variant and sportier than skoda's
octavia combi
the experienced variant of the leon st
offers three centimeters more clearance
all-wheel drive and plastic under body
cladding
now he's going to see what it can do on
the street and light terrain
the new leon experience is seatt's way
of saying
it doesn't always have to be an suv its
off-road appearance
also looks at home on city streets from
a technical standpoint
it has a lot in common with the vw golf
but in comparison with the gulf the leon
is sportier and appeals to the emotions
the additional clearance has taken
nothing away from its dynamic
handling on curves
the experience is a special model leon
which boasts top
quality equipment the body is beefed up
with molding for a more rugged look
while inside it features all-wheel drive
connected to a haldex clutch
once the experience leaves the smooth
asphalt it puts in a decent showing
off-road
experience einhold believes the word
experience connotes adventure and says
adventures are better talked about than
personally had
the leon experience will most often be
used for runs to school
or work and maybe for an occasional trip
into the mountains
and if the chalet lies a bit far off the
beaten track the experience can handle
steep inclines surprisingly well
order
the additional clearance is very welcome
on rough terrain
gravel roads and slopes the experience
can even edge down
steep hills without giving the driver
panic attacks
we tested the strongest diesel engine
with 135 kilowatts and a 6p
dsg transmission it accelerates from
zero to 100 kilometers per hour
in a decent 7.1 seconds and reaches a
top speed of 224 kilometers per hour
it consumes just 4.9 liters of fuel per
100 kilometers
the suspension ensures a comfortable
ride even over
uneven ground
reinhold confirms that it feels steady
yet when he takes the curves with a bit
more speed
the front axle feels somehow different
he cites two reasons
one the all-wheel drive allocates the
power between the rear and front axles
according to need two the experience has
a differential lock
that strives to keep the varying speeds
on the front right and left wheels in
sync
it provides a feeling of better grip
that's especially nice on wet pavement
snow and ice
from the outside the additional
clearance is immediately apparent
the wheel arches are framed by black
plastic cladding
which gives the design more of a
practical off-road look
the black plastic skirting contrasts
with the painted surfaces at the rear as
well
the cargo space is a respectable 587
liters which more than doubles to 1
470 liters with the easy back release
rear seats down
the folding mid gate is practical for
carrying long objects
like skis the experience logo
graces the steering wheel and orange
stitching sets a colorful accent
the dashboard controls make for a tidy
impression
and the multimedia unit is accessible
over a 5.8 inch screen
in the center console the seats provide
good lateral support for a comfortable
ride
in germany the normal station wagon with
the strongest diesel engine starts at
just over 30
000 euros if you want the all-wheel
drive version you'll need to buy the
experience which cost
two thousand seven hundred fifty euros
more the experience
reinhold points out that the experience
is a bit pricier than the sea
leon without the x but for that you get
an outdoor vehicle with a stylish
appearance
and this is one of seatt's main
advantages over its competitors
who all too often flood their wares with
the charm of a used car salesman